il y a l'accès aux fleuves et des airs
de petits villages d'un côté et de
l'autre des terrains contaminés qui
attendent une nouvelle vocation il y a
une qualité de vie paisible pour une
population plus âgée que la moyenne
montréalaise mais aussi une
multiplication des événements violents
[Musique]
l'inflation de la santé 3 la sécurité ce
sont les trois sujets qui revient
aimantablement aux portes avec les gens
Karine Boivin Roy qui espérait être élu
avec Denis Coderre aux dernières
élections municipales veut passer au
palier supérieur
merci beaucoup et il se chuchote que la
nouvelle kakiste à l'ambition de ravir
au parti libérale la circonscription
enjoule Louis Riel représenté par
listerio pendant 20 ans des belles
choses qui s'enviennent un nouveau
centre médical qui serait ouvert à
proximité également la rénovation et
puis la modernisation de l'hôpital
maison neuve Rosemont sur ces questions
de santé la gestion de la pandémie
pourrait faire basculer ces deux
électrices péquistes vers la calque ce
qui les retient c'est un éventuel
raz-de-marée Bleu Poudre
démocratiquement
de l'opposition j'aime pas les gens qui
sont trop en avant un peu plus loin dans
l'Est moi c'est jasmin
il dit qu'on prendre ceux qui ont eu le
goût de l'aventure kaki mais il croit au
retour de ses électeurs moi j'ai fait
partie de cette corde de gens qui ont
été déçus dans les dernières années du
Parti québécois et le Parti québécois
est revenu sur sa mission fondamentale
je pense que ici on a un rôle à jouer
pour renverser le déclin du français et
faire en sorte que Montréal redevienne
la ville quelle doit être la métropole
française d'Amérique libérez le
potentiel de l'Est c'est le vœu formuler
à répétition par les élus et candidats
ces dernières années et sur le terrain
les acteurs attendent encore ça prend
deux pôles d'innovations dans l'est de
Montréal ça nous prend un mode de
transport structurant qui reconnecte
directement au centre-ville et il faut
aussi accélérer la décontamination des
sols il y a des sommes qui ont été
réservées mais là il faut l'accélérer
le désenclavement du territoire doit
passer par le futur reine de l'Est qui
est de retour sur la planche à dessin ce
jour-là une salle comble assiste à une
présentation d'une autre version du REM
proposée par deux anciens du comité
d'experts il critique l'efficacité du
projet sur la table en ce moment qui ne
se rend pas jusqu'au centre-ville il
suggère d'ajouter ce lien en tunnel
j'entends un appui presque uneanime on a
aujourd'hui dans la salle tout ce qui
peut être représentatif de l'Est de
Montréal des tables de quartier aux
entreprises privées des institutions
d'enseignement au service de l'Est je
crois que tous les pouvoirs politiques
vont être à l'écoute c'est une bonne
proposition le député sortant de la
Fontaine appuie cette idée d'une
connexion directe même si elle n'est pas
chiffrée mais avant les questions de
transport celui qui espère être réélu
pour la quatrième fois en temps d'abord
agir pour la sécurité nous voulons qu'il
y ait davantage d'intervention en amont
soutenir nos organ communautaire
soutenir nos intervenantes et
intervenants de rue qui travaille sur le
terrain et qui viennent notamment
diminuer la tractivité des gains de rue
sur nos jeunes dont ces trois bastions
libéraux ou kakistes Québec solidaire et
le Parti conservateur risque de récolter
des appuis insuffisants pour faire
pencher la balance et que ce soit avec
un vent de changement ou de continuité
les résidents de l'Est ne veulent plus
du statut quo ici Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada Montréal